hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play cry of fear
alright now a while back there was
another patch released for cry here
which added quite a few more custom
stories so I'm just gonna go down the
list and knock em all out
starting with her media cuz I'm a pansy
been awhile since I played cry fear
actually but you all know how much I
love it
oh boy introduction I loved her we were
in love yes the bond between us can't be
broken by anything but I see it in her
eyes fear but a fear of what while I'm
here to protect her what could she be
scared of yeah that doesn't sound crazy
at all Jonathan lockdown Jones
the pretty common theme of the main
character being pretty insane
haha yes I think this is a fake door
haha
really now fake doors at least you're
honest about it let's wait to dark in
here
I need to find something to light my way
oh how about this Wow Oh woah woah hi hi
hi hi can I have that where the heck did
you come from Twiggy a holy God guitar
nope not about there we go back with pro
skills again save you know save oh yeah
you can only save that's right I'm an
idiot you can only save with certain
things so yeah I got a comment on that
weirdo guy murdered him cuz he was in
your home ha ha what you got what you
got what you got - nothing nothing
nothing nothing nothing nope
there you go that's right get down
what's this they're waiting for you
darling upstairs with love her hugs and
kisses hugs and kisses for kisses and
hugs
I think this is a fake door what you
talking about fake doors there be fake
doors are you crazy
oh that's new okay say what now
okay I'll stop here you told me do need
no Lackey back in your lanky oh yeah
what how's it
who's that what the why not huh talk
about a illogical oh okay I guess I'm in
the woods now
oh nice choice
haha she was behind door number three
the handle burns my hand all right door
number one then fine he's gonna be like
that huh what am I breaking news no
maybe if I just use my yes
lack so whatever who's there to do haha
no
okay I like you my fist anyway haha
last time play was back in August god
it's about time I got back into crime
fear all right area yeah
general number 54 today he took me out
to a movie and then the restaurant
afterwards it's really not like him to
be this huh nice to me it almost felt
fake as if he planned this date so very
long ago I fell asleep at his place
afterwards the happiest I felt in a long
time next thing I remember is waking up
with my head pounding I had what did you
had
oh you freaky weirdo yeah don't think
about crap here I don't miss his health
frakked-up all the months were
absolutely no idea where I was and the
strangest thing is that I didn't even
feel scared the place felt familiar to
me somehow he appeared out of the gloomy
shadows and I then made the connection
that I was changed to the wall in his
basement
in that moment some things about him
came together in my memories that
flicker of insanity the wild evil look
in
I see you there I see you pop you're
quick Wow no give me that
nope hey you look okay up there
how's it hanging stop the pain you can't
stop the pain oh never mind us obscene
and I'm going to see much Freaker in
this place
a fierce amount of pleasure from this
just as I thought I would die from this
pain the nail pulled free the worst of
the pain was gone but this throbbing
bleeding stub was agony in itself and
entry fun times said no one ever
I know I wasted two bullets there
knocked got to find a key wait I see a
ladder
because I did not I am a liar I'm a
dirty dirty liar okay where is this
so-called key but I saw like a way to
get down there's a way
oh no wait this is upstairs nor that Oh
find the bed do you have it do you have
it you douche I'm gonna punch your knees
off come here oh right in the knee I
know that your weak spot haha yeah ow oh
oh oh you guide I'm just too strong for
my own good
where is this key Oh what's this aha
I found something going down Oh what the
hell abliss right through you
his eyes he's oh this is supposed to
open his eyes he sometimes got too late
I came to the realization this man is
insane my thoughts were interrupted by
an excruciating pain in my foot followed
by the sickening sound of my toenail
being pulled out the pain would not
cease he did it slowly methodically by
the look on his face he was getting
pleasure from that experience I got a
key
can I get out of this creepy ass prison
a nice theme for today you know locked
yes got it the cows I got fists of fury
any monsters coming back
okay okay okay huh ha I saw you what
were you goddammit what's that say press
come on press for forgiveness
I don't think only the light is your
only chance bask in its warmth and
safety do not take the things you hold
dear for granted okay I probably
shouldn't wander off into the darkness
whatever what have I ever done anything
correctly pretty sure that was gonna
happen
[Music]
stupid yeah blah blah do that okay press
for forgiveness okay
OOP more of a lever not a button
okay I didn't expect that
oh man okay maybe I got a pull the lever
and then BOOM oh hey don't kill me sorry
don't kill me ah oh the light oh I'm an
idiot okay you all probably got that
right away I'm just I'm I'm so stupid
about everything that I do
okay now the light is going to move I'm
going to move with it now there it is I
see it that's actually really cool is
that breathing I hear my name I got I
think I think I'm gonna get my gun never
a bad choice oh man okay enough with the
breathing
what are you that lady from slender mod
can't run nice Elise
why oh okay hi
whoa who's there oh you know oh you
don't mess with me you made me do it
I didn't wanna you crossed the line huh
where's your light don't skate light
stop zigzagging
where you going like light ah no oh oh
oh yeah
[Music]
this narrow walkway now I don't like
this I better not fail I had best not
fail you're gonna let me fail Oh God
which way do I go
not that way not that way we're up no
this way ah ha ha I made it all crap
oh come on
you got do this to me when I haven't
saved one of these the right door
No
none of those we're the right door haha
don't worry dad I'm just gonna okay
Elmo is there explosive I'm gonna stay
in the red cuz that's going out of it
dude stop dude stop it stop right I
sound like a crying huh what the hell oh
just take Tuesday oh where am i where am
i where am i where am i what happened
what this is your exile die it will all
end uh I don't think so I think I better
go for a nice swim
you cannot evolve alright I guess I'll
get my toes a little wet it does not
look like happy fun jump cut obviously
we're playing the character of a crazy
guy this looks good
I like this exactly the type of area
where out it man ah oh come on
we know I'm healing well it's going on
what's the deal what's up
the end I don't think so
don't tell me it's the end side then I
would have done the stupid thing where I
didn't end the video when I was supposed
to don't tell me that don't hey I will
punch you to oblivion
meow can I go under you can I go away
from you what what no no I refuse oh
come on don't be like that
come on there's gotta be something else
okay Vienna uh I don't believe that come
on don't end it like that it's not right
it's not right it's not right
is that the end is that really really
really really really the end like that
pie was and it's only like that alright
I guess I guess that's the end the holy
crap um yeah I kind of wish I went just
through the whole time obviously you're
seeing this all in one episode because I
just stitch them together but yeah
that's well that's disappointing it's
like two of the two the cracker because
some stories I played so far have been
kind of just a wee bit disappointing in
the endings but if that's it that's it
then so thank you all so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed this rather
short brief cry for your custom story
and hopefully I will be playing more in
the near future so thank you all so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video
bye-bye